Learner A4: الو
Learner A4: الصوت عمار.
Learner A6: الصوت تمام.
Learner A4: سامعني ولا.
Learner A6: أنا سامعك تمام هون سماعيل.
Learner A6: الو السلام عليكم.
Learner A4: الله سامعك.
Learner A6: تمام.
Learner A4: ، سامعك كويس.
Learner A4: اهدني.
Learner A6: هو الحمد لله أنا بصراحة يعني مبارح كل اللي عملتو إني عملت مقش مش عارف المفروض يديني تاني كده.
Learner A4: ما انا اخدتو امبارح واشتغلت عليه شوية.
Learner A6: طيب حلو في الدنيا.
Learner A4: بس لسه لما بيخش في في حاجة تضرب.
Learner A6: أم
Learner A6: أنا فعلا مش فاهم بالظبط هو يعني المشكلة اللي بتحصل هل هو الموديل هل اف بي اي الدنيا.
Learner A4: ألو.
Learner A4: صحيح معاك معاك.
Learner A4: عندي لما تيجي حوالي حتة والحاجات دي
Learner A4: كنت مغيرهم كم يوم عشان شغلها بروجكتها تاني معرفش هو حراسه.
Learner A4: أنا.
Learner A4: هو.
Learner A4: كلهم أصلا.
Learner A4: مدينة مساء النور.
Learner A4: طيب لو هو ورنينغ في اللي هو بتاع البايتون.
Learner A4: في في 91.
Learner A4: آملين.
Learner A4: إن ديفايت.
Learner A4: أيوة.
Learner A4: بس يعني في 1 إيه.
Learner A4: مال الدوتن دي.
Learner A4: يعني زي ما عندي مشكلة في المكتوبة مش مزبوط شيء كدا
Learner A4: في 1 بقى تاني اللي هو بتاع تيست أصلا.
Learner A4: لا، لا.
Learner A4: ما مش عارف مش هذه المشكله هو بيقولي باك عند الجزء يعني يقولك بويلاند.
Learner A4: ده بسببي.
Learner A4: ما بحرفهم منن.
Learner A4: طيب أولا أنا عامتا عملت تغييرات البارح عملت شوية على في الإيميج وأصدر صور جيده
Learner A4: بس لما كان بيدخل في الباي بلاين كان في حاجة بتضرب في النص مش عارف كانت
Learner A4: بس أيا كان يعني المفروض هي محلولة
Learner A4: يعني لو فتحت اللابتوب تاني هبعتلك كل حاجة عندي يسلمك راكب.
Learner A4: أنت شو بتقطع سمنة مفتوح
Learner A4: اشتغلت أنا على وابتعد وطلعت نتائج حلوة.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A4: بس بس لما بيخش بقى في نفسه مش عارف إيه اللي بيحصل؟ فأولا.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A4: أفتح اللابتوب لأول ملف أول ما أفتح اللابتوب.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A4: طيب ماشي.
Learner A4: ادوني بس 5 دقايق كده وهدخل تاني.
Learner A4: براحتك يا أستاذ.
Learner A4: مثلا مصطفى يخش الوادي حاليا وإن شاء الله.
Learner A4: هو انتو جالكو الفوميشن عده دا.
Learner A6: ده مأنا دخلت رحت بعتله على طول قلتلو ازاي احنا مش هنتصرف ازاي بعتلي نفس الحوار اللي بيبعته صح آسف، ده غلطة من عندي مش عارف البلبلة
Learner A6: بس.
Learner A4: مع حوار لو انت عايز شغال أصلا في مش معدل يعني يعني.
Learner A6: مش فاهم يعني عدى أساسا عدا إزاي يعني انت لسه عامله
Learner A6: إحنا لسنا واخدين الطاست يوم الاثنين ده
Learner A6: يوم الاتنين الرسمي يعتبر ما هو انت لحد ده هوت هم نزلوك تسكت غلط.
Learner A4: أيوة
Learner A4: فرنج.
Learner A4: مزنوق زنقة أو أحشا.
Learner A6: يعني اهلا.
Learner A4: ما عندي عندي لا الامتحانات لسه. مش عندي خلصت لآخر كويز امبارح بس عندي تسليمه ديسكاشن بكرة.
Learner A6: أم.
Learner A4: معلش انت خدت المادية.
Learner A6: كومبيوتر انتيراكشن.
Learner A4: أي وين كومبيوت إنتراكشن.
Learner A6: نعم، نعم، ما يخافش ربح.
Learner A4: يعني مدة التكلفة.
Learner A6: بتاخد فيها مثلا.
Learner A4: احنا يعني هو مش عارف اشرحلك الموضوع مش عارف المركز تي اي ومركز الحاجات دي.
Learner A6: بصراحة برضو.
Learner A4: يعني في وفي حاجات في ليلة كبيرة يعني
Learner A4: فالمواعيد مالي الخميس اللي فات ان في بروجيت الخميس اللي هو بكرا.
Learner A6: وكله بيجوا وراء بعض.
Learner A4: ما هو المشكلة؟ طلب مني اننا آي كتير.
Learner A4: بس الحلال خلصوا بروجكت مبارح خلصنا كله اللي فضت.
Learner A6: أوف.
Learner A6: دلوقتي على نفسك بالليل.
Learner A4: ما هو الفكرة أشتغل عليها يبعثولي يمني طيب اللي هو
Learner A6: والله آخر آخر يومين ان شاء الله النهاردة وغدا.
Learner A4: على.
Learner A6: على سبرينتس ونبقى خلصنا على ما خلصنا الشغل على بروجكت ماشي.
Learner A4: يعني أنا بكرة ممكن أرجع وأكمل المشكلة في بروجكت بتاع بكرا.
Learner A6: تمام موفقة عبدالله.
Learner A4: هو أنت أنت ما كنت مجر إيه.
Learner A6: اسمي برضه خلصت خلاص الحمد لله السنة دي خريج.
Learner A4: منتزهات الجنوب.
Learner A6: دفعة 2,000 وأنا داخل الكلية الفين و2 أنا مواليد 2,004 نفسها.
Learner A4: انت سكنت كلها امتى.
Learner A6: 2,000 واتنين من 2,000 وتنين ل 2,006 بس كده.
Learner A4: 2,000 واتنين.
Learner A6: أه.
Learner A4: أنت مواليد 2,000 وتنين يعني.
Learner A6: لا، لا، أنا 20,002,000 إثنين و20 معلش أنا داخل.
Learner A4: من.
Learner A6: معلش معلش معلش.
Learner A4: يعني.
Learner A6: إحنا بنركز برضه نؤدي.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A6: لا لا 2,004.
Learner A4: كويس.
Learner A6: إنجيل.
Learner A4: حسبنا الله يعني صح.
Learner A6: يدوبك شهر 6.
Learner A4: هو انتو كلو عندكو كم سنة.
Learner A6: هي 4 بس.
Learner A4: ما هو في جماعات ثانية؟ 3.
Learner A6: لا لا إحنا عندنا 4 مشترك هي.
Learner A4: معلش.
Learner A6: جنرال و2 تخصص.
Learner A4: ما تعرفش تسمع عن تذكر ولا لأ.
Learner A6: ليه.
Learner A4: جماعة اسلاسكا.
Learner A6: لا بصراحة فيها تلاتة.
Learner A4: هي جنب نيوجيزة.
Learner A6: ده.
Learner A6: نفسها صح.
Learner A4: 3 سنين بس هم قذيفة كمان حتى الساعة 6 بالليل.
Learner A6: لا يا عم أنا تقريبا الجامعة عندنا ما رحتش سنة أولى كلمة أول وشكرا.
Learner A4: ما إحنا عندنا من شون أنا كنت كنا نكمل سياسي.
Learner A6: حضور ولا لأ.
Learner A4: يعني.
Learner A6: الحضور على اي درجات لازم تحضر ال سكاكاشن لو ما حضرتك.
Learner A4: لو ما حضرتش أنا ما حضرتش يعني 4 مرات بتعملي ديبريس من المادة أصلا
Learner A6: الكلام ده أنا ما حضرتش مرتين على بعض.
Learner A4: ما حضرتش.
Learner A6: كيف.
Learner A4: لما ما حضرتش.
Learner A6: ولا أي حاجة بخش امتحان عادي خالص ما عنديش أي بني آدم بيفتح.
Learner A4: لا إحنا عندنا لو 25 في المية.
Learner A6: المندب.
Learner A4: ا ما بخش.
Learner A6: إحنا دكتور قال لنا كده الدكتور دخل قالك وش كدة قالك اللي حيريب مش عارف إيه عشان العميل الجديد العميل الجديد قالك 3 أيام وحرمان.
Learner A4: أنت أنت أنيواع.
Learner A6: القاهرة.
Learner A4: القاهرة. انت عندكوا دكتور رضا اللي مشي صح.
Learner A6: رضا الكريبيون.
Learner A4: وهذا كان بيدينا بيدينا مواد بس ما كانش بيجي.
Learner A6: الحمد لله بجد نوايا تفتح في إيدو.
Learner A4: هو بصراحة يعني هو أنا كنت بشوف إسمه.
Learner A6: أنا.
Learner A4: ثانوية.
Learner A6: أي حاجة
Learner A6: كده ما كانش بيفرقني الدكتور أوي سفن وبحضره فمش عارف يعني أنا أهم حاجة بالنسبالي طلال إمتحاناتك كويسة خلاص ما عنديش مشكلة غير كده أنا ماليش دعوة بتشرح بتعمل أنا مش ححضرلك بصراحة يعني.
Learner A4: أنت كنت يعني إيه انت صرت صدقي يعني ولا
Learner A6: هي سلف ستادي بنلاقي امتحانات قديمة بناخدها نحفظها نخش بس كده خلصت تقريبا دا كل اللي أنا كنت عامله.
Learner A4: هو إنت إيه اللي خالي كان بخليك ما تحضرش.
Learner A6: تضييع وقت الشرح أنت مش متخيل كلية عندنا بتضيع فيها وقت قد من الشرح في حاجات فعلا ما فيهاش لازمة يعني تروح مثلا عارف.
Learner A4: فرنج ماشي.
Learner A6: إنجليش
Learner A6: فالمادة دي إنت كل اللي بتعملوا فيها إنت بتروح السكشن المعدة تطلعلك شيك تقعد تحلك شيك بإيديها يقولك حرفيا ومش عارف دي هنعملها إيه بنحسبلك الماسك وكل حاجة بيديها كده بورق وقلم و
Learner A6: بس أروح أستفاد يعني اللي هو هي حاجة كويسة كإن يكون جوا العلم
Learner A6: بس خلاص يعني أنا جوا العلم قوي كده يا عمي خرجني شوية.
Learner A4: يعني.
Learner A6: ما كنتش بحب احضر بصراحة وإزاي يعني أنا من النوع اللي هو ما ببكي بحب انام في البيت.
Learner A6: شكرا جندي ما.
Learner A4: جماعة.
Learner A6: هذا.
Learner A4: إلى.
Learner A6: الجماعة بعيد عني ثلث ساعة تقريبا يعني نص ساعة ماكسيموم
Learner A6: أنا لو خدت أوفر موتسيك بالظبط 5 دقايق ببقى قدام البيت.
Learner A4: يا سيدي. انتوا عندنا من عندكو لا اشكك الدفعه 20 تنين و20.
Learner A6: بيعرف اسماعيل.
Learner A4: رؤى ما كانت موالية علي انا.
Learner A6: شو أم.
Learner A6: أنا سمعت ده قبل كده بس أنا مش عارف هي اللي في دماغي ولا لأ.
Learner A4: مشاعرك، لا.
Learner A4: وشعراء.
Learner A6: لا أنا ما أعرفش مش فاكر شكلها بتكلم هناك كان في وحدة اسمها تقال بتشرح لنا بروجرام سولڤينج.
Learner A4: صندوق.
Learner A6: لا، لا، أنا داخل إثنين و20 فاكر تخرجت قبل ما أنا خش.
Learner A4: ما هي كنت بتتخرج 22.
Learner A6: إمم.
Learner A4: يعني سنة أولى.
Learner A6: لا بالزبط ف. لا، لا.
Learner A4: ستسمع الدكتور أحمد فاروق.
Learner A6: رحمة فاروق ممكن تقريبا.
Learner A4: وعن الجمل على اليوتيوب لي علاقة عامود الكلية عندنا عميد الكلية عندنا كلها عارفين.
Learner A6: والله جنب.
Learner A4: هو المفاجأة أصلا اللي فاجأنا فيها إنهم ما يتخرجش من على مصر.
Learner A4: ، خرجت خرجت للتجارة.
Learner A6: كمان.
Learner A4: بس.
Learner A6: كل.
Learner A4: هو للعلم بطريقة مش طوعية.
Learner A6: عندنا السميده بتاع الطلاب.
Learner A4: بالعربي فورفان كده.
Learner A4: كمل معلش.
Learner A6: إحنا عندنا الوكيل بتاع الكلية خريج هندسة مدني اساسا.
Learner A4: مشي هندسة مش سيجارة.
Learner A6: مدى.
Learner A4: فاهم.
Learner A6: أبعد حاجة برضه عن.
Learner A4: أيوة يعني في حاجات زيمرتها يعني لكن حد التجارة أصلا مالوش علاقة بالمجال خالص.
Learner A6: شكرا رح يوقفوا.
Learner A4: أنا بقولك شرح.
Learner A6: يمكن الدكاترة ما عرفوهش عشان أنا فعلا كنت الدكتورة بتاعت مشروع التخرج اللي معانا هي اللي كنت بحضرلها
Learner A6: وحتى مع حضرتلوا هجمة والله كثير.
Learner A4: 1,000,000.
Learner A6: ما.
Learner A4: بعض.
Learner A4: عشان.
Learner A6: ما هنستلمه. بحضرتك أنا حرفيا ما بقدرش بص أصل إنت المحاضرات ومش عارف وكده
Learner A6: ما فيش أستفاد حاجة لو حضرتلوا
Learner A6: أنا فعلا حضرت سنة أولى ما استفدتش حضرت سنة تانية حضرتين ما استفدتش من سنة تانية ما حضرتش قررت من سنة تانية بس
Learner A6: فأنا من سنة تانية لسنة رابعة. أنا قررت إني أحضر أي حاجة تاني يعني.
Learner A4: انت فكرتني والله يا دكتور كان جاي من عندكم برضو كان اسمه إيهاب الخضري.
Learner A6: يا ده الوكيل؟ انا لسه بقولك خريج هندسة مدنية.
Learner A4: كان اسمه كان اسمه الخضري.
Learner A6: هو ده أنا بكره.
Learner A4: سمراني كده وبنضرة.
Learner A6: عارفة ما أنا بقولك ده الوكيل بتاع الكلية.
Learner A4: ، أصلا. دعيني.
Learner A6: شايف.
Learner A4: أيوه كان بيجي بصي وداني مادين بس وداني مادة.
Learner A6: أيوة.
Learner A4: ودالي كومبيوتر.
Learner A6: فرنج.
Learner A4: وكان.
Learner A6: لأن في الكلية خليني أجيب فيها كام.
Learner A4: أنا شلتها معاهم والله.
Learner A6: لا.
Learner A4: والله.
Learner A6: أول دي أجيبها في حياتي.
Learner A6: جبت معادين.
Learner A4: أنا عايز أقولك إن إحنا دفعتنا إحنا أنا داخل الجامعة.
Learner A6: يي.
Learner A4: ، لي في الجماعة دلوقتي لظروفهم. ما هي؟ فإحنا دفعتنا
Learner A4: كانت حرفيا يعني في 1 كان معنا في الدفعة.
Learner A4: لا هو كان.
Learner A6: ده حاجة كويسة ولا وحشة.
Learner A4: لأ يعني هو مأجل الصناعة العامة عشان لما يخش الجامعة يبقى جاهز.
Learner A6: كان داخل الأصل.
Learner A4: هو كان داخل سنة أولى يعني عنده.
Learner A6: شغال.
Learner A4: وأصلا. أنا معاي اثناشر لجنة لسه.
Learner A6: سنعود.
Learner A4: كدا.
Learner A6: عفوا ده والله كان بيخوف.
Learner A4: فهناك.
Learner A6: تخش حتلاقي ناس كده اللي هو تحس نفسك إن إنت يمكن.
Learner A4: ما هي النقطة في حاجة إن ده كان.
Learner A6: كمان.
Learner A4: لأ يعني مش هو أنا بتكلم ده قبل الدفعة الدفعة كلها داخلة.
Learner A6: عارفين.
Learner A4: هم من هم عندهم 5 6 سنين عارفين إنهم داخلين.
Learner A6: يراه جد.
Learner A4: فكان على دفعتنا إن إحنا أصدر دفعة. عدت.
Learner A4: بس خدنا مع رواليتي أعلى 1 جايب في الميد 28.
Learner A6: لا هذا الخضر ده.
Learner A4: اللي هو أصلا. أنا بكلمك على ناس أنا بكلمك على ناس بتقفل وهي نايمة.
Learner A6: أيوا أنا بقولك إيهاب الخضري دكتور مريد عارفوا إيهاب الخضري عمل فينا إيه في المادة دي قال لنا جزء كامل مش جاي في المية تيرم دخلنا المية ترم لقينا جايب عليه بتاع 6 أسئلة
Learner A6: بتاع 7 درجات تقريبا على الجزء اللي قال بقي ببقوا بتاع ده مش جاي.
Learner A4: مستوطنين يعني إحنا أصلا.
Learner A4: لقيت مش شايف فيها دي اللي يعني.
Learner A6: أول يوم كنا.
Learner A4: هو بيدينه أصلا كان ساعتها الكورونا
Learner A4: 5 6 كله. لو أنا حافظهم دخلنا الإمتحان لقيت العيادة.
Learner A6: مرسي.
Learner A4: واضح في اللجنة.
Learner A4: اللي هو يا جماعة هو ده.
Learner A6: بس.
Learner A4: هو كان.
Learner A6: والله بجدولك أول يوم في الكلية أول ما دخلنا قعد يكلمنا كده والنظام هنا غير ومش عارف إيه ولآخر يقول لنا وسابنا مشي.
Learner A4: هو بيعظم والله هو حاسسنا إن إحنا مش زي كهربا ده.
Learner A6: محمد ده بقولك دخلنا في القاهرة كده نفس الكلام هزقنا في القاهرة ومشي هو رجل مختل.
Learner A4: يعني.
Learner A6: جد والله راجل تعبان في والله ما بطيب.
Learner A4: والله.
Learner A6: جد الراجل ده انت عارف ان الراجل ده من أسباب إن أنا غيرت مشروع تخرج كامل فكرته والدكتورة تانيين
Learner A6: يعني غيرت فكرة مشروع التخرج غيرت تماما بسببو هو دكتورة تانية.
Learner A4: معليش انت صوتك بعد شوي.
Learner A6: كنت بقولك إن هو من أسباب إن أنا غيرت فكرة مشروع تخرجي كامل.
Learner A4: كان
Learner A6: لا وأنا كنت مقدم فكرة مشروع تخرجي عن المجتمع. ماشي
Learner A6: دخلنا المسابقة دي هو مسك على مسابقة لو تسمع عنها اسمها نيكستس.
Learner A4: تقريبا
Learner A6: بس
Learner A6: فأنا كنت داخل فكرة المشروع فاحنا بنعرضه هو ودكتورة ثانية. الفكرة عمالين تهزيق ويا ريت تهزيف الفكرة هما بهذوقوا فينا إحنا
Learner A6: اللي هو إزاي ده مشروع تحركه على كده هتبقوا مش عارف إيه يعني في دلوقتي جايين تحكم عادي بتهزقني
Learner A6: والدكتورة التانية تقولنا مش عارف إيه لا المفتكرتوا دي كلها ملهاش لازم
Learner A6: يعني حد يقول لحد كده في وجهه.
Learner A4: ما حج الله.
Learner A6: بجد والله.
Learner A4: صراحة.
Learner A6: عشان الفكرة فعلا بتدعمنا نفسيا.
Learner A4: ملك قلت ليه.
Learner A6: بقولك الحمد لله إني غيرت الفكرة لأن الفكرة كانت بتتعبني نفسيا والتين نفسه كان حيتعبني يعني أنا أنا فعلا أكتر حاجة فرحان. إني أنا خلصت أنا في الكلية دوت. إن أنا مش حتعامل مع تيم مشروع التخرج تاني يعني.
Learner A4: ، طب خلصت خلاص.
Learner A6: ما أنا أقصد إن أنا فرحان إني خلصت كده يعني أنا مش فارق لأي حاجة في الكلية قد مش حتعامل مع تيم ده تاني.
Learner A4: والله كل 1 بيشتغل لوحده في الجماعات كلها. مش واضح إن هم جينا هنا.
Learner A6: أنا كلمني بصراحة، لا، أنا بجد كان الناس اشتغل لوحدي. أنا ما عنديش مشكلة أشتغل لوحدي وألاقي إن أبقى معاه حد أقوله يعني خلصنا.
Learner A4: يعني.
Learner A6: كذا.
Learner A4: في ناس أكيد في ناس شغالة معاك يعني.
Learner A6: إحنا كنا 5 ما فيش غير 1 اللي بيتابع معايا شغال بس مع نفسه شايف اللي هو يديك الشغل وخلاص 1 منهم دخل بعث لي
Learner A6: بروجكت كامل ماشي
Learner A6: ابعتو ازاي توقع يعني انت تقولو انت تقوله الطبيعي جدا أنا أعملهم جيب يعني خش وابعته على جيب أي حاجة لأ
Learner A6: بعتلي الفايل بتاع البروجكت وشوية على الواتس أنا ما أعرفش. أساسا هو ازاي الواتس فوق الجيغا بس
Learner A6: أنا لقيت حاجة كده قدام مرة وحدة بتتباعت أنا أنا فقدت اللوت.
Learner A4: ما يعني بصراحة هو أنا جيت أبا ما كنتش يستعملوا كتير
Learner A4: وكان أنا دلوقتي ببقى شغال لوحدي أو حد فيها بنزل معاه
Learner A4: إحنا نازلين مع بعض كذا مادة فكل 1 فينا بيشيل بتاع المادة
Learner A4: أو مثلا اللي هو إيه إحنا 3 4 مثلا كل اتنين شغالين في بروجكت.
Learner A4: فجيت ده ما كناش بنشتغل به أوي.
Learner A6: أنا أنا بشتغل.
Learner A4: شغالين مع بعض.
Learner A6: بس فكرة إن إنت دلوقتي لما تنال بروجكت جيجا وشوية
Learner A6: طب حتى قلي إن أنا حبعتهولك أي حاجة إزاي إبعتو واتش يعني أنا بالمشروع ييجي على الواتس
Learner A6: يعني أنا كنت فاهم وعملها ازاي.
Learner A4: معاك معاك.
Learner A6: بس يعني بصراحة الحمد الله إني خلصت منهم بجد.
Learner A4: أنت أنت اشتغلت قبل كده ولا ليا مرة.
Learner A6: شغل شغل لا إنتيرنز يعني زي نفس الحالة دي كده.
Learner A4: أخدت كورسات قصدي ولا دي أول حاجة خالص.
Learner A6: لا، لا خدت. نقلت ، لو تعرف رواد مصر الرقمية نزلت معاهم مرتين كنت أساسا باكينغ دوت نت
Learner A6: بعدها بصراحة فكست دوت نت و فكست ال باك اند كله قلت الإيه آي عجبني أكتر
Learner A6: كملت معاهم خدت معاهم عاجبلي إيه وبس.
Learner A4: هو أنا دي أول.
Learner A6: عادي. يعني أنت شايفله
Learner A6: طالما بدأت تقدم ده المطلوب تقريبا يعني حتى الآن والله أنت مش متخيل قدمت على كم حاجة ويلاقي الريجيكشن في وجهي مفيش رد أساسا فا.
Learner A4: مع.
Learner A6: راوي.
Learner A4: حقولك.
Learner A6: أنا بقولك فالواحد تعود خلاص يعني أنا هو مقدم تقريبا حاجات ما فيش أي حاجة أنا بس أنا قدمت ومش عارفله ده لسا مقدمو النهارده
Learner A6: حيجي. إمتى الرد الله أعلم هل هييجي رد أساسا الله أعلم
Learner A6: بتنزل تحته شوية نفس الكلام الميل بتاعي كله عبارة عن.
Learner A4: بؤدي.
Learner A6: ما في شغل الحمد لله.
Learner A4: لا، لا مشكلة،
Learner A6: بالزبط.
Learner A4: من سنتين. عملت انترفيو أون لاين كمان
Learner A4: قعدت يعني قعدت الانترفي كله انا بعرفه ك إمبريشن
Learner A4: معك يبقى هذا ليس شيء حلوه يعني.
Learner A6: أم.
Learner A4: أه المتينغ كانت 5 واربعين دقيقة هي قعدت معاك 45 دقيقة.
Learner A6: لا على فكرة مش.
Learner A4: تعرف.
Learner A6: شرط.
Learner A4: هو كان في حلو.
Learner A6: عارف 1 صاحبي لسه حرفيا والله لسه مكلمني من يومين انترنيسوفتور ديسم.
Learner A4: فوليو.
Learner A6: مش باليو لا اسمها انكرت.
Learner A4: مائي.
Learner A6: الكرت تقريبا لو أنا فاكر، صح.
Learner A4: بقى سويسرا هو ممكن.
Learner A6: كويسة.
Learner A4: والفكرة. إن أنا يعني أنا أنا برد انا برد ده على كل.
Learner A6: حلو والله.
Learner A4: بس كان هو أنا بذورتي أصلا شغال في باليه بس هو في بتاعي.
Learner A6: أم.
Learner A4: يعني فا فقال لي الأبر قلت له والله قعدت معي الخمسة و40 دقيقة قال لي طيب ده مؤشر حلو
Learner A4: سترد علي الاسبوع القادم أعرفلك الدنيا من عندو قهوة
Learner A4: عدا الأسبوع اللي جالك قلت له لأ قلي شوف ليه مش مقتنعة بشخصيتي.
Learner A6: السبب.
Learner A4: جد بجد والله.
Learner A6: يعني مش مقتنعة.
Learner A4: مع هتخطبني ولا.
Learner A6: طب بجد ده والله الإتش عارف بيطلع منهم مرض غريب.
Learner A4: هو الفكرة إن هو يعني أنا لسه أصلا. ما رحتش.
Learner A6: كمان طيب يعني شخصيتك إزاي.
Learner A4: إن شاء.
Learner A6: عملتها إزاي.
Learner A4: و ماشي ما أنا الكلام؟ ده كنت بعملوه في الجامعة.
Learner A6: بالزبط.
Learner A4: شخصي
Learner A6: أنت أولا إكتشفت حاجة إنت عارف إن الشغل في الكلية غير خالص. الشغل الحقيقي أنا 1 صاحبي شغال سوفتوير تيستر فعليا يعني هو شغال حاليا في سوفتوير تيستي.
Learner A4: بس.
Learner A6: الكلية بس خلي المتر بتاع صوت الكلية جاء في الآخر تقريبا.
Learner A4: ما هو بص أنا كلهم يعني.
Learner A6: ده بجد أنا عشان كده بقولك أنا ما كنتش بحضر لأن إيه بدأت أشوف دوت شغال ويقولي إنت ما بناخدش الحاجات دي أسأل حد يقولي لا طب خلاص احضر على إيه خليني اقعد في بيتنا وبتذاكر بقى يوتيوب كنت بلاقي حاجات
Learner A6: قصيرة بتنزل دعم وكده خش بس وظيفها كده بصراحة.
Learner A4: من شارع جامع.
Learner A6: أنا خدت معاهم كورس لو تعرفوا بتاع اندرو إن جي السوبر فايز.
Learner A4: لا مش قادر غالية.
Learner A6: على فكرة حلوة كتير دكتور سيرة.
Learner A4: لا مش قصدي.
Learner A6: أيوا.
Learner A4: جامد بس.
Learner A6: هي الفكرة بس كل كورساتها حاليا مدفوعة وحوار إنه كان بيعمل فايننشال إيد
Learner A6: عشان هو كسر الخمسين دولار 50$ بصراحة أكيد يعني فا.
Learner A4: و.
Learner A6: تقول له عايز فاينانشال دي.
Learner A4: غوغل عامة بيعمل حاجات برضه وفي كامبريدج عند حاجات.
Learner A6: كان.
Learner A4: فرصة و كامبريدج كامبريدج أوكسور حنان الاثنين هول الاتنين عم بظن.
Learner A6: أنا بصراحة حاليا بحاول يعني اللي هو إيه بحاول أدور على خبرة عملية
Learner A6: حاجات تهمني في الدقيقة، أبدأ أشتغل أشوف أشوف إزاي شغلي بيمشي اتحط على توسكات معينة أجربها
Learner A6: رغم إني أنا شايف حتى الآن المية جنيه اللي احنا بنعمله والكلام ده إنت برضه يعني ما فيهوش الشغل الحقيقة قوي يعني زي ما إنت شايف مش.
Learner A4: مقاس البيت.
Learner A6: وغير حتى مش عارف مين معاك.
Learner A4: واللي بيخش ده على فكرة يعني
Learner A4: مش حقولك كله عشان في ناس بتخش على اقل قليلا وبتطلعش احضر المتينغ يعني معرفش احضره لظروف في وقت.
Learner A6: أيوة بالظبط.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A6: خبرة معاك.
Learner A4: ما أنا اللي زنقت نفسي الزنقة دي وبصراحة وظيفتي قال لي انت مفروض تنزل عشان انت ما نزلتش خالص
Learner A4: قال لي ماله انزل مادتين. انزل مادتين واشتغل عادي.
Learner A6: كمان.
Learner A4: اها
Learner A6: كلامك.
Learner A4: التخرج بتاعي لوحدي.
Learner A4: أول ما بدأ الشغل سدته خالص
Learner A4: عشان بعملو في الجامعة ولا ولا حاجة أخلص معاكو.
Learner A6: ماعديش على.
Learner A4: المعادلة الشغل. حيبقى كدا دلوقتي عايز.
Learner A6: فأنا إكتشفت اكتشفت فعلا أهو
Learner A6: بس زي ما قلتلك هو الشغل اللي حاسو حيبقى يعني أكيد هيبقى في نظام أكتر شوية يعني إنت على الأقل حتبقى هيبعتولك كل شوية إنه معلش سوبيشن اتقبل معلش أصل السوبيشن ما تقبلش ديد لاين خلص هو ديد لاينست يعني إنت تخش تسألوا هو ديد لاين إنت يقولك الخميس يبعتلك التلاتة ديد لاين
Learner A6: طب يعني اعمل
Learner A4: والموضوع. يعني انت لا مانك شغال ولا منك ما اشتغلتش.
Learner A6: بالزبط. أنت أخدت الإكسبيرينس بس دلوقتي تحس إنها ل 6 برضو.
Learner A4: هو هو بياخدك باي ستب. أنا ما أعرفش. الراوند جاي راوند جاي ممكن تبقى ليفل أعلى من كده الله أعلم.
Learner A6: في.
Learner A4: أعرف أجنبي.
Learner A4: أنا لما سجلت سجلت شهر 8.
Learner A6: يعني كل الدراسة بدأت صح.
Learner A6: الدراسة، بدأت.
Learner A4: ما أنا كنت في 6 بامتحن.
Learner A6: ا.
Learner A4: فاينل انت كيكتهن برضو انت.
Learner A6: ما أنا مخلص نص 6 يا فندم.
Learner A4: مع نفس الكلام فرحت رحت مقدم في الشهر. 7.
Learner A6: طيب حلوة.
Learner A4: وقلي شهر 8 عشان كده كده في شهر تمانية.
Learner A6: بالزبط 8 داخل على الفايدة.
Learner A4: والله وال فاينل أصلا يعني آخر الشهر ده.
Learner A4: بس أنا نازل اكشن دي كومبيوتر أوحش من بعض.
Learner A6: مش بجد.
Learner A4: مش المشكلة مش المادة والله.
Learner A6: ما دل والله أساسا يعني أنت طول ما إنت عارف إن كان في دكتور بجد المادة بتاعته مش أسوء حاجة يعني والله أنت لو فكرت فيها كنت ماتريال مش أسوء حاجة بس الدكتور مريب والله بجد إنت مش متخيل الدكتور مع دكتور هو كان مع الرجل ده.
Learner A4: ما.
Learner A6: حصل خلصنا أنت متخيل بيبدأ المحاضرة محاضرتنا ساعة ونص ماشي خذ المحاضرة بتاع 4 ساعات 5 ساعات
Learner A6: من قبل العصر للمغرب.
Learner A4: معلش هو خد هو خد خد مواعيد الدكاترة ثانية ولا
Learner A6: هو دلوقتي ببقى خلاص ما فيش معاد بعديه فبيعيش حياته ياخذ المدرج ويفضل قاعد لما الناس برا تقول له يا دكتور المعاد ده حنقفل حرفيا بيقولوا حنقفل.
Learner A4: اليوم، خلص.
Learner A6: لنا يلا امشي.
Learner A4: طبيعي جدا.
Learner A6: المغرب. أنا ما صليت العصر.
Learner A4: بس هو مش بيقولنا عضو يعني يشرح لأ هو محاضرة كنت بسأل الدكتور أحمد فاروق عبدالرحمن فرودة
Learner A4: هو بدأ معانا في المواد اللي هي وانت لسا وانت لسه داخل الكلية لو بروجرام بروجرام تو.
Learner A6: أم.
Learner A4: الأساسيات اللي في الكلية اللي على أساس بتعرف تفهم أصلا،
Learner A4: فهو كان بيعمل حاجة كان بيحط يومين في الأسبوع
Learner A4: لكل ماده من مواد يعني التي نشرحها وهو بسميه ووركشوب شوف احنا نخلص سيولنا إمتى
Learner A4: فالذي يخلص ثلاثه الذي يخلص هو إحنا دلوقتي كنا كلنا نروح على الساعة 4
Learner A4: من الساعة الرابعة بقى ممكن الساعة 9 بالليل هو مش معدك غزو عنك
Learner A4: هو انت بتيجي هو بيدينا في مساء كتير وإنت طبت حل
Learner A4: النقطة بقى في هو انت لو زرعت ممكن تروحله وهو ما يدركش انت
Learner A4: يعني لو اديك لو اديك انت
Learner A4: اللي انت ممكن تبقى حاجة صغيرة قوي وعايزك تشغل دماغك وعايزك انت اللي تشغل دماغك
Learner A4: بس هو كان في ناس كتيرة مش عارفة تحل المسألة. خالص نقعد حوالي بقى كلنا
Learner A4: طربيزة كبيرة عريضة كده وبيض يشرح طبعا إيه
Learner A4: في كمية إيه فور والله بدون الورق لدرجتين فوق بعض الورق.
Learner A6: بيد الدكاترة دي بتبقى مضحكة.
Learner A4: لا، هو بص هو هو بحب العلم
Learner A4: يعني كنت دكتور الطلبة كلها بتحبه مش عارف هو هو عايز يفيدك فاهم
Learner A4: وأسلوبه حتى مش مش بايخ يعني عارف الدكاترة دكتور
Learner A4: لو فصل المحرر تقولها بكرة مش فاهم فيقولك إذا كان نايم مش فاهم حد فاهمنا.
Learner A6: اي بالزبط.
Learner A3: أو أنت رجال.
Learner A4: كفاية.
Learner A6: لا شئ لو.
Learner A4: بس.
Learner A6: ما.
Learner A4: أي حاجة خالص.
Learner A3: ما يعني يعني عارف حاسس يعني.
Learner A6: اها.
Learner A3: هو خلاص معاش في حاجة تفوت فاهم قصدي.
Learner A6: بالزبط.
Learner A3: بس اللي هو سمعت احمد فاروق كده في النص.
Learner A3: انت تتكلم عن مصر يا باشا. هذا اعظم دكتور.
Learner A4: مش لسه بقولك والله.
Learner A6: اها.
Learner A3: اقسم بالله.
Learner A4: أقصد.
Learner A3: انت بتعرف شو إسمك.
Learner A6: في دماغي لو هو اللي في دماغي مش اللي في دماغي.
Learner A4: هو أقرع.
Learner A3: لينس.
Learner A6: يبقى هو ال جيمز كان.
Learner A3: هو كل شباب.
Learner A4: شكرا.
Learner A4: وأرى الله عليك.
Learner A3: نعم.
Learner A4: و شكرا يا شباب.
Learner A3: كاريزما كاريزما موت.
Learner A6: بس أنا ما حضرتلوش ولا مرة.
Learner A3: هو تقريبا خسران ده عايز أقولك أكتر دكتور استفدت منه
Learner A3: في العلم بتاع الإيه عموما كلاح مسروق.
Learner A6: يياه.
Learner A3: لا والله.
Learner A4: أنا كنت.
Learner A6: محاضرته المتسجلة لو.
Learner A3: دكتور رهيب يعني.
Learner A6: دول.
Learner A3: بس رهيب جدا يعني.
Learner A4: طب إنت عارف هو خريج صح؟
Learner A3: لا مش ما عملتلوش كشف حقيقة بس عارف.
Learner A4: خليني.
Learner A3: طب أنزل.
Learner A4: المصدر.
Learner A3: حضرتك الساعة 8 الصبح.
Learner A4: ما.
Learner A6: بحضر.
Learner A3: ما فوتسوليش محاضرة.
Learner A4: تاخذ الصدمة ولا.
Learner A6: الجيل.
Learner A3: في.
Learner A4: وليش ناس مثلا خريج تجارة.
Learner A3: ده ملح.
Learner A4: والله.
Learner A3: عايز أقول عايز أقول لك مرة مرة.
Learner A4: مقياس.
Learner A3: الضليعة بشكل.
Learner A4: أيه.
Learner A6: يلا.
Learner A3: ضليع في العلم بشكل مرعب مرة
Learner A3: صح كده مارها واقف كده في وسط المقابلة.
Learner A4: النهاردة في الجامعة والله.
Learner A6: في.
Learner A3: والله ده أنت محجوز جدا اصلا دم خفيف جدا ومره واقف في وسط المحاضره هكذا
Learner A3: مش عارف كانت ازاي ازاي موضوع اللزوم بيتعمل.
Learner A3: الزمن والحاجات دي فمرة دي.
Learner A4: على حاجة بقى عارف لو هو مش عارفو حيروح هجرومي.
Learner A3: يعني سبب المحاضرة سبب الموضوع سبب كل حاجة وجاي على الموضوع قسما بالله من كثر ما هو.
Learner A4: بحب ال يحب العلم بطريقة تخوف.
Learner A3: إمم من اكثر الناس.
Learner A4: وحقلك على حاجة ما بينسى اسم حد.
Learner A3: يا رووج.
Learner A4: صحيح؟
Learner A4: ما بينسى إسم حد ما بنسى إسم حد وهقولك مثلا لو جبت دفعة خريجة من 2000ستا10 حيبقى عارف يفرق ما بين الكود بتاعك والكون بتاعه.
Learner A3: الموضوع كنت صعب قليلا، لكن هو كان ياتيني مؤيدين من عندنا في الكليه كان.
Learner A4: حيقولك أنت عامل الكود ده إنت واخذ الكود ده من فلان.
Learner A3: يا لهوي
Learner A4: المصحف مرعب هو لوحده.
Learner A3: ذاكرتي. احتاج ذاكرتي.
Learner A4: هو انت مش محتاج حد محتاج ولا محتاج مواعيد هو لوحده كفاية ما شاء الله.
Learner A3: ما قصدك ما بينزلش معاهم فعلا.
Learner A4: هو دلوقتي بقى.
Learner A3: المواضيع.
Learner A4: بقولك على حاجة هو كان طول عمره مشكل وحده لما الهبل اللي حصل في الصناعة العامة لكم سنة اللي فاتوا دول
Learner A4: المجاميع. قلت والناس بقت بتخش فعدد الناس اللي بتخش الكلية بقى أكبر من الطبيعي ومعظمهم.
Learner A3: أم.
Learner A4: داخلين الكلية مش.
Learner A3: أيوة. أيوة شو فهمني هيك أم.
Learner A4: يعني إحنا عندنا إحنا الدفعة اللي هي طالعة رابعة دلوقتي دي أول دفعة كبيرة عندنا في الكلية يعني.
Learner A3: أن.
Learner A4: أكبر دفعة عندنا كانت متين و30 1 الدفعة دي من 50 1 فا.
Learner A3: انا عايز أقولك.
Learner A4: أول ما تدف عليك؟ دخلت إبتدى يدخل مع مستحيل هيخلص كل أسبوع.
Learner A3: أكيد أكيد
Learner A3: لا، هو كان بيشتغل عندنا من غير موعدين إن إحنا كنا تقريبا تخصص من التخصصات القليلة فعلا كنا حوالي 230
Learner A3: وكان.
Learner A4: ما.
Learner A3: الواحد.
Learner A4: تقريبا.
Learner A3: عايز اقولك كان بيدينا ماده في قمه التعقيد كان بيدينا.
Learner A4: بيديكو
Learner A3: جينز الجينز دي هي قائمه على.
Learner A6: الفكر.
Learner A3: اللي هو بالزبط يعني قائمة على فكرة الجينيراشن يعني كل الحاجات هو جاب الجينيراشن منذ بدء الخلط
Learner A3: انت فاهم الفكرة يعني فهمها جيدا جدا بي سي
Learner A3: ماشي ده الجريزم المعروف جدا بيعمل بيعمل بيعمل كومبريشن حلو كده.
Learner A4: ده غبن.
Learner A3: ودرس لنا هذا من اشهر من اشهر الكريستس اللي بتعمل توكينازيشن أو لبتعمل يسموه اي ربي
Learner A3: اسامة سعيد أنت آي برضه ورثه.
Learner A6: المشكلة.
Learner A3: بيعملوا من 10 اللي بتعمل إمبريس
Learner A3: يا ابني الحاجات فاهمها. انظر، انا متخرج من اي سنه الاشياء فاكرها وافهمها وممكن اعرف احل المسائل فيها حرفيا.
Learner A6: والله غيم.
Learner A3: من كثر ما هو يعني كان كويس جدا في الشهر.
Learner A4: أنا عايز.
Learner A3: فعلا.
Learner A4: هذه المسائل والحاجات.
Learner A3: لا شك.
Learner A4: بيقولي الامتحانات. هو كان هو دائما كان قبل الامتحان بشهر أو شهر ونص بيدينا فايندرز من أول امتحان ليه لآخر إمتحان عمره.
Learner A3: وبعدين مدرسين الثانوي بيقعد يراجع معه يعني مثلا لو خلص.
Learner A4: الله.
Learner A3: قبل.
Learner A4: أم.
Learner A3: القديمة طال عمرك.
Learner A4: فجوز اختي كان بيقولي بيقولي إحنا إحنا الإمتحان اللي بنعمله في باليو أسهل من كده.
Learner A4: هو قال لي تبدي ليحطها في بلاغه.
Learner A3: ده.
Learner A4: متخيل.
Learner A3: حرام.
Learner A4: هو مخلي مش عارف يحل تمام.
Learner A3: لا لا ده هو رهيب جدا. جدا. انت عارف انا في امتحان للامتحانات وكان ليا في موقف مشكور يعني
Learner A3: كنت قاعد بحل مع كنت قاعد بحل في اللجنة قدامي اللي هو ماي بيست فريند وقاعد على شمالي مابستريت حلو كده
Learner A3: وانا بحضر كل المحاضرات بقى انت فاهم الفكرة
Learner A3: بحضر في الامتحان كله والدنيا كويسة وجئت على سؤال ما عرفتش تحلو
Learner A3: كان لي فكر رياضية اللي هي كانت بتقول
Learner A3: ان هو انت لما تيجي تضرب توداي منشنز ببعضهم بزيرو.
Learner A4: مش.
Learner A3: كان هو تكلم فيها في قلب المحافظ. انت فاهم الفكره والعيال جنبي عطلان في السؤال وجاي مش عارف وانا ايضا خارجا. نحن خلصنا الامتحان انت فاهم الفكره بس فضل سؤال فاهم قصدي
Learner A3: فاضل السؤال فيه فكره كان هو العب في المحاضره وكنت اناقشت معه فيها ابتكرته وهو يقولها في المحاضره فقمت بجانبي وقلت له
Learner A3: انت فاهم الفكرة.
Learner A4: بحور.
Learner A3: والمعلومة كانت بتحل كانت عاملة زي كويس كان سوق إكويجنس لو ضربتوهم في بعض.
Learner A4: دي.
Learner A3: هيلاقيك، وزير النزل جينز بورغ.
Learner A4: ما.
Learner A3: تدري.
Learner A4: ماشي ماشي.
Learner A3: وده تقريبا كان سؤال في البي سي
Learner A3: تقريبا كان سؤال في البي سي اي كان سؤال في هو بي سي اي فزي ما بقولك انت كان لو ضربتهم في بعض لو هم كانوا بزيرو
Learner A3: فبالتالي انت كده بقى عندك فاهم قصدي عندك فعملت إكويشن وحدك انت فاهم قصدي
Learner A3: لكن وقتها الذي هو الاثنين في اللجنه القادمه انت فاهم قصدي.
Learner A4: الوطني.
Learner A3: والله يا أخي.
Learner A4: فاكر أصلا.
Learner A3: المحاضرات في حاجات يقولها السطور
Learner A3: بيعمل معاك يعني يوم جايبها مثلا في الامتحان انت فاهم قصدي الامتحان يشوفك بتاع ولا لا، فهو فعلا ذكي جدا جدا في وضع الامتحانات.
Learner A4: يعني.
Learner A3: غير ان هو من أغرب الدكاترة في موضوع الامتحانات. لو انت عندك امتحان مثلا وهو قبلها بمحاضرتين براجع الامتحانات القديمة بتاعته
Learner A3: انت فاهم حاجة انا اول مره رايت ان الدكتور بيراجع يعني إيه بيراجع اصلا انت فاهم.
Learner A4: وبعدين ثانية واحدة، نكتبلك كود على البرج من غير بنك.
Learner A3: دي حاجة برضه.
Learner A4: 1 بيكتبلك زيرو زيرو فولز على البرج.
Learner A3: كنت سألت سؤال في مشروع تخرجي
Learner A3: يعني من كثر ما هو يقولك ضليع كنت سألته على إيه هو احنا ينفع نيجي نادي
Learner A3: ينفع. نعملها زي اليونيفيل موضوع كثير معقد فاروق فاهم قصدي
Learner A3: من اكثر الدكاتره التي استفدت منهم في التخصص بتاع اي هو دكتوره اسماء ومن اكثر. الدكاتره التي استفدت منهم في الحقيقه عموما. كالدكتور محمد الرميدي.
Learner A6: لا والله.
Learner A3: انت عارف انا اخدت معاه اربع كورسات يا فندم.
Learner A6: على.
Learner A4: فرنش.
Learner A3: نعم.
Learner A4: كنت قاهرة ولا بعدها.
Learner A3: لا، لا، كنت القاهرة وبعد ذلك. مثلما اقول لك الدكتور بالمناسبه محمد الرمل اخذ دكتوراه خاصته من معهد البحوث.
Learner A4: إنت أي دفعة.
Learner A3: ما هذا اللي يحصل؟ أنا دفعت خمسه و20 21 ل 25
Learner A3: الدفعة اللي بعدي انت مش دافع 26
Learner A3: الدكتور محمد الرمل يحبها جدا لدرجة ان هو عايز يجمعنا وشوفنا تقريبا كم يوم.
Learner A6: الله يجامل.
Learner A3: قوي بحبنا جدا.
Learner A6: ده أول حاجة أول حاجة خالص أول مادة بتعطينا اول.
Learner A3: أيوة أيوة الدنى الدني اول مادة خالص الدني اول مادة خالص اللي هي الكمبيوتر.
Learner A6: بالزبط.
Learner A3: وبعدين بعدين بروجرام ون حلوة كده.
Learner A6: أم.
Learner A3: وبعدها.
Learner A6: ولا سوف يو.
Learner A3: لأ الدنق بيه وشفته اربع كورسات من اكثر الكورسات الاساسية في الكمبيوتر عموما.
Learner A4: بالرواية.
Learner A3: كان زمنه رهيب اللي هو إيه ما انا قلت سي اس بروجرامينغ ون أوب وبعدين
Learner A3: فأخذت الاربع فورصات معايا فعلا الدكاتره استفدت منهم في الكلية يعني
Learner A3: بما ان عمر ساكن في اكتوبر.
Learner A6: ما أنا ساكن بعيد قوي عن أكتوبر.
Learner A3: يعني.
Learner A6: والله ما أعرفش لا مش في القاهرة. أنا في الجيزة. أنا ساكن جنب الجامعة.
Learner A3: ايضا ساكن في الجيزه. انا ساكن في الدقي مثلا.
Learner A6: سكنت في المونيب لو تعرفه.
Learner A3: أعرفه طبعا.
Learner A6: عرفت.
Learner A3: مجلس.
Learner A6: مكي متر.
Learner A3: كان عندك كرسينا.
Learner A4: عمر.
Learner A6: أنا ساكن هناك.
Learner A3: فاكر عند محسن.
Learner A6: تشيكن أوريج.
Learner A3: طيب.
Learner A6: في.
Learner A4: بص انا اطلع برا أكتوبر مرة في السنة تقريبا ما اعرفش الحاجات دي.
Learner A3: ممكن اجيب الولد.
Learner A6: أي مكان بالنسبالي يعني.
Learner A3: ما أنا فاهم انت في وسط الدنيا كلها عزيز.
Learner A6: بالزبط. ما أنا عشان كده بقولك إحنا.
Learner A3: شو إسمه خلاص والله نتقابل قبل اليوم بتاع الاسبوع
Learner A3: بما ان نحن عملنا حاجات مشتركة فيه.
Learner A6: في.
Learner A3: الموضوع لازم.
Learner A6: انا كدا كدا الاسبوع الجاي ان شاء الله ابقى فاضي يعني كده كده أنا بمجرد ما اطلع فاضي.
Learner A3: وأنا كمان برضو بالمناسبة.
Mentor A: أم آمين.
Learner A3: منذ سفر.
Mentor A: معلش عالدخول المكيف.
Learner A3: لا، لا ما فيش مشكلة.
Mentor A: إلى أخبار.
Learner A6: بخير؟ الحمد لله.
Learner A3: والله كرة القدم معظم الحاجات اللي حضرتك تكلمت فيها تقريبا خلصت يعني وجربناها وأعتقد حضرتك شفت هم بيبعتوا.
Mentor A: أم طيب عملتوا إيه في موضوع بتطلع أس بي جي كقوت ولا تقريبا عمر كم مسك الموضوع ده.
Learner A4: هو أنا أخلص بس مش عارف أرني الكود مش عارف شو عندي مشكلة في ال وبحالها دلوقتي.
Mentor A: طب هل جربت أي تيست جاني؟ ولا إنت ولاقيت تشغله بوزت ولا إيه.
Learner A4: معليش أنا مش سامع حضرتك.
Mentor A: جربت تطلع أيها أم.
Learner A4: لا ما انا لسا مش عارف انا كنت مبارح ثاني عندي في الجامعة فغيرت الينفيرنت
Learner A4: فلما رجعتها تاني هو في حاجة بقى وأنا بحاول أشوفها من لابتوب
Learner A4: المشكلة مش في الكود المشكلة اللابتوب عندي.
Mentor A: ليش أنا فاهمة. أنا فاهمه طيب والباقي تمام يعني جربتوا.
Learner A4: ما أنا بحاول أشوف المشكلة فين عشان اعرف لحد دلوقتي.
Mentor A: طيب ماشي أوكي عمر لو إنت قصدي أسامة، هل جربت مثلا تحط حتى لو بلاس هاندرز لل كودز لأي.
Learner A6: هل يسبب.
Mentor A: طلعهولك جوا وتشوف.
Learner A4: تقريبا هو كدرك.
Learner A6: نفس الحوار. بالظبط. اللي كنت بعمله هو دورهم بس كان رفعت مبارح آخر حاجة عملتها، على النيل، وهو كان شغال عليها.
Learner A6: فكان المفروض قلي انو عمل كم أبديت كده هو في الكود
Learner A6: بس يعني هو دخل معانا في الأول بعدها خرج فا
Learner A6: آخر حاجة كانت المفروض بتظهر معاه دلوقتي.
Mentor A: طب هل معاكيز مثلا أو كأي حاجة يعني مثلا نشوف عمر ولا معاك.
Learner A6: هو لا أنا اللي كان بيطلع معاي حاليا لسه برضو زي الأسد اللي فاتت يجب أن يكون.
Mentor A: محتاجين. نشوف بس أنا سكنت.
Learner A6: إمم.
Mentor A: يعني طيب بصمة عمر يزبط الدنيا هنعتبر
Mentor A: إن عمر بيطلعلك ال اس بي جي كود كود بلوكس دي.
Learner A6: تمام.
Mentor A: ممكن تقول ممكن تشوف ال إيه حاول تشوف من عمر
Mentor A: هل هو رن حتى مرة ولا بس لو هو معوش أي حاجة ممكن تجيبها من
Mentor A: يعني اكتب لي جي كل ده.
Learner A6: فهمتو.
Mentor A: ماشي شوف بس دي تتحط إزاي هتعرف تاخدها مثلا لو هو لو عمر طلعهولك يعني طلعهالك مثلا سين ون وده الكود بتاعه سين تو ده الكود بتاعه غزا
Mentor A: انت تلوم على نفس الستروكتور أونلاين مع بعض لو إنت تشتغل على كده وتاخد ده بس تشوف ازاي حتحطه جوا وتشوف بتاعه صح ولا لأ.
Learner A6: تمام ماشي.
Mentor A: ولا مش فاهمين.
Learner A6: هو يعني أنا حاخد دلوقتي المفروض
Learner A6: حخلي مثلا حيطلع في نفسه كتجربة وأخذ النهائي بتاعي أخليه أشوف إزاي إزاي الإسم الجديد.
Mentor A: بالضبط عشان بس نختصر الوقت بدل ما تفضل لحد ما عمر.
Learner A6: فهمتوا طب خلاص بسيطة بإذن الله.
Mentor A: أوكي طيب أول بقى ما تعمل كده ممكن تبعتلي الفايل على طول.
Learner A6: تمام أكيد ماشي.
Mentor A: ماشي ابعتهولي مش بكرة ولا أي حاجة عملته النهارده بالليل. إبعتوا لي برايفات على سيرك
Mentor A: الاشتمال فاين بس بي جي.
Learner A6: اللي هو آخر حاجة وخلص الوقت النهائي، صح؟
Mentor A: لو شفنا الفايل بالأزمة.
Learner A6: تمام ماشي.
Mentor A: الموضوع ده حيحاول النهارده بالليل.
Learner A6: أكيد ححاول ان شاء الله أخلصوا دلوقتي على طول اساسا.
Mentor A: خلاص أوكي.
Learner A6: يعني.
Mentor A: يلا باي باي خلطة بس.
Learner A6: موجود.
Learner A4: 8
Learner A4: يا عمتي.
Learner A3: عادي عموما مش مشكلة يعني نحن لا نقول شيء خطا.
Learner A4: انت استفيت استفيت على طول انت.
Learner A3: أنا لا يا عمي. أول وحدة.
Learner A4: لا مؤسسة.
Learner A3: مجيء.
Learner A6: إمم.
Learner A4: المحيط.
Learner A3: بتاعتك هعمل إيه أف.
Learner A4: ولا يهمك.
Learner A3: هي اللي جت زنازين.
Learner A4: هو المشكلة إن هي تتكلم بسرعة، وأنا.
Learner A3: تقريبا تقريبا بتبقى في الشغل. فربنا.
Learner A6: أه.
Learner A3: و8 وبالنسبه للاب يعني انا على المستوى الشخصي ارى عظيم والكلام ليس هناك مشكله هذه مشغول عليه
Learner A3: والله طلع كان لي مصلحه يعني نقدر نقول اي.
Learner A4: معايا اننا في اللابتوب.
Learner A3: أم.
Learner A4: فا فكنت مش قادر إيران عشان أركب في مشكله.
Learner A3: طيب ما انتي جرافيتي؟ انت جرافيتي ايت.
Learner A4: أنت معايا خالص.
Learner A3: دي بس.
Learner A4: والله لا
Learner A3: ليه بس هو يبقى صديقك في الصندوق.
Learner A3: نعم.
Learner A6: أنا عامل فلتوتر كله دي.
Learner A3: طيب.
Learner A6: اها.
Learner A4: اهلا وسهلا عن عمي.
Learner A3: شكرا.
Learner A4: وحدة بروفرجين الجامعة.
Learner A6: طب مدح.
Learner A3: يجب.
Learner A6: حيبقى مفتوح.
Learner A4: المشكلة بقى في إيه ما ينفعش أصلا عليه الجماعة لازم يبقى فيرشن للأكونت بس خلاص.
Learner A6: عقلتي جيمينوي على الجامعة نفسه مش على.
Learner A4: لا، ما هو بإميل الجامعة؟ أنا عندي أكسس للبروفير.
Learner A6: تمام.
Learner A4: يعني عشان معاي عشان الجامعة كانوا عاملين فترة كده.
Learner A6: ما هو أنا ده واخدو، كنت أقعدوا على أكاونت برايفت الجامعة.
Learner A4: ما هو كان.
Learner A6: كونت الجامعة عشان يديني على.
Learner A4: ما أنا لما جيت أعمله عادي مرضاش لما عملته قالي هو أصلا هم عاملينو.
Learner A3: بس انت تربطهم ببعض يعني تربط الإيميل الشخصي بتاعك بأمين الجامعة تفهموا.
Learner A4: بال
Learner A3: يمين الجامعه هو اللي بيديك الاسس واليمين الشخصي بتاعك ممكن تربطه بامين الجامعة.
Learner A3: انا كنت اعمل من كدا مع
Learner A3: يعني أضفت لل أكاونت بتاعي على جيب اللي أنا عامله أصلا مش فاهم قصدي.
Learner A4: بحاول افندم.
Learner A3: انت ممكن تروح تربط أكاونت في الجامعه بال أكاونت بتاع جوجل جيمي نايت تربط الأكاونت اللي هو بتاعك
Learner A3: الشخصي بال أكاونت جي مينايل تاع الجامعة انت فاهم حاجة.
Learner A4: أربط.
Learner A3: طيب والاثنين شغالين شغالين مع بعض يعني انت حاولت.
Learner A4: فنان.
Learner A3: زين.
Learner A4: لا قصدك يعني إنت قصدك بتاعي.
Learner A3: انت بتاخد الاكل من يومين صح.
Learner A4: باخد
Learner A3: الاكسس بتاع جيمنا الجامعة.
Learner A4: هي الجماعة عامة الجنرال عامة كانوا عاملينو فترة كده كانوا عاملين للسودان يعني حتى.
Learner A3: إمم.
Learner A4: البروزر.
Learner A4: لما تخشي بين الجامعة بيديك البلايست.
Learner A3: تمام مهو انا بقولك انت ممكن تزود الايميل بتاعك الشخصي بالكلام ده.
Learner A4: مع.
Learner A3: ممكن تسير عليها عشان تبقى مرتاح شوية.
Learner A4: انا عايز اقولك اننا انا عملت قبل كده كذا مره تيميل وكنت الحاجات البقايه دي وبرضه نشاهدها.
Learner A3: ما في مشكلة انت ممكن طيب في اصلا ناس بتعمل اشتراكات ما عليها.
Learner A4: أنا أنا شغال ازاي. انا شغال أنا منزل تري إي آي الإكسيشن.
Learner A4: هو زي كرسي لو ما تعرفوش.
Learner A3: أيوة.
Learner A4: على وأنا أصلا يعني سليم.
Learner A3: طيب زي الفل زي الفل، لكن انت محتاج.
Learner A4: ما وصل.
Learner A3: يعني بتشوف حالك.
Learner A4: أنا.
Learner A3: لو ما لقي معايا ناس بتعمل اشتراكي برو على.
Learner A4: أنت.
Learner A3: تقريبا آخر حاجة شفتها كانت السنة تلتمية و50 دي حاجة موت ضحك كده يعني.
Learner A4: بكم.
Learner A3: بتلتمية و50 جنيه استنى اطناعشر شهر والله.
Learner A4: ابرج.
Learner A3: انت فاهم قصدي، فممكن أبعتلك.
Learner A4: ما وصل لما جيت عشان كنت مضطر يعني ما كنتش عايز أشتري حاجة بصراحة إنه هو.
Learner A3: أم.
Learner A4: اسعارهم كلهم 20$ ثلاثه دولار في الشهر.
Learner A3: الدنيا.
Learner A4: أخي بس رحت على فكرة هو هو
Learner A4: هو انت جرفتي خد نفس الفكرة.
Learner A3: مايو.
Learner A4: يعني أوقات.
Learner A3: طيب إنت حاول تبعتي.
Learner A4: بدأ بعد كدا كورسر بعد كده أنتيغرافي وعلى فكرة في سكود دلوقتي.
Learner A3: أيوة أيوة على المستوى الشخصي للموضوع الخاص بمشروع التخرج وابعثه لو انت تعرف تعمل.
Learner A4: هي الميزة في الموضوع إنه يعني أنت ممكن تأكسسهم التلفون لو انت بتريد لو انت.
Learner A3: أيوة أيوة؟ فهمت قصدك دي تعتبر لي فوق الأنتيغرفت.
Learner A4: ما هو على فكرة هم يعني فإيه أنا بقدر أشوفهم بيعملوا هو شغال بس هو عامل.
Learner A3: طبعا.
Learner A4: وهو بيقولي بس.
Learner A3: تنفعك كثير جدا في مشروع التخرج.
Learner A4: مع.
Learner A3: تمام.
Learner A4: اللينك. اللي أنا لينك ده.
Learner A6: الدنيا.
Learner A3: ممكن تسألش عليا قلي انت حتعمل إيه كدا مع عمر
Learner A3: عمر خالد في موضوع انه انت محتاج الجسم منه.
Learner A6: ما
Learner A6: أنا كل اللي هاوي يعني أشوف اللي هيطلع منه أشوف دلوقتي بتقولي المفروض أحط بليس وولدر نفسه فأنا أروح تيست ثاني بس الفكرة إنه درغام كان بيقول عمل حاجات
Learner A6: فأنا عايز أشوف الحاجات اللي خلصها عشان ما عدلش زيادة كان قصدي إنو.
Learner A3: من.
Learner A6: بعتها بيقول إنه ده بيطلع أوجد دلوقتي بس في مشكلة بس
Learner A6: هي دي اللي كنت عايز اعرفها هو قال لنا كدا في البداية، وقال لنا 5 دقايق داخل بس
Learner A6: أنا مش عارف.
Learner A3: وساقط.
Learner A6: بس.
Learner A3: وممكن نبعثله على لسه معانا بكرة وممكن نبعثله على.
Learner A6: بالضبط أنا ممكن.
Learner A3: عادي.
Learner A6: برضه ثاني أفضل مكمل أحاول بس أحط يعني في اللي أنا أعملها ححط البلاس و حخلي.
Learner A3: الزيتي.
Learner A6: يعملي شوية حاجات للسينز اللي حتطلع وبس وهشوف حيطلعلي ازاي النهائية.
Learner A3: ماشي عشان هي محتاجة.
Learner A6: بالزبط.
Learner A3: طيب.
Learner A6: جدا.
Learner A3: طيب ممكن تبعتوا ندخل.
Learner A6: خالص بي.
Learner A4: والله يعني إحنا ممكن نكلم بعض إحنا عايز حاجة ولا أروح من عندك.
Learner A3: كده.
Learner A6: أوكي.
Learner A3: ونحن منعمل كدا عموما يعني.
Learner A4: 1,000.
Learner A3: تمام كده.
Learner A6: بإذن الله.
Learner A4: أهلا وسهلا.
Learner A3: ربنا يسلمك ان شاء الله حد محتاج إن إحنا ندخل ولا حاجة مع بعضنا ما عنديش مشكلة.
Learner A6: خلص بإذن الله.
Learner A3: لحد ما نسلم على خير ان شاء الله الدنيا تبقى.
Learner A4: إن شاء الله يعني أنا أنا بحاول احل الوقت وموعدكم.
Learner A3: الله يوفقك.
Learner A4: قريب عشان غدا.
Learner A3: الله يهمك الله يهمك.
Learner A4: خلصت الشغل.
Learner A3: الله يعافيك.
Learner A4: حبش.
Learner A3: كله يخلص كلو يخلص
Learner A3: ما تقلقش كله بيعدي وبيخلص ياكل.
Learner A4: ما إن شاء الله.
Learner A3: إمم.
Learner A4: نعم، قريش.
Learner A3: ربي يوفقك غدا إن شاء الله.
Learner A4: الله يخليك.
Learner A3: أيوه السلام عليكم.
Learner A6: أهلا وسهلا.